Florida is the latest state to approve
severe restrictions on abortion access
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis signed
a bill to establish a six-week limit on
abortions if the state's current 15-week
law is upheld in court meanwhile the
Biden Administration wants the Supreme
Court to get involved in a legal
challenge to a commonly used abortion
pill Nancy Cordes is at the Supreme
Court with more Nancy good morning good
morning Dana yes Florida is a great
example of how quickly and dramatically
state laws are changing in the wake of
the Supreme Court's decision last year
to overturn Roe v Wade women in Florida
the nation's third most populous state
will now only be able to get abortions
within the first six weeks after
conception a point at which many women
still don't even know they're pregnant
ah
amid protests in Tallahassee Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis signed a six-week
abortion ban late Thursday night it's
called the heartbeat protection act we
have the opportunity to save lives we
are creating
a death sentence for women Florida now
joins the ranks of a dozen
republican-led states that have enacted
near total bans on abortion in the 10
months since the Supreme Court undid
nearly 50 years of federal protections
and GOP lawmakers aren't stopping there
in Texas Republicans are pushing to
block websites that provide information
about abortions just this month Idaho
made it a felony to help a minor get an
abortion out of state women should have
the freedom to make decisions over their
own bodies now several democrat-led
states are stockpiling abortion
medication the latest front in this
fight last year
the attacks were on abortion procedures
this year medication abortion what's
next contraception birth control all
eyes are now back on the Supreme Court
after a conservative Federal appeals
court panel imposed new restrictions
Wednesday on access to the abortion drug
mifa pristone blocking mail delivery of
the pill shrinking the window in which
women can take the medication from 10
weeks down to seven and requiring
in-person doctors visits it's going to
benefit America's women and girls across
this country how is it going to benefit
them
they're gonna have protections again
having to go and meet with a doctor
beforehand to determine whether she has
life-threatening complications before
taking these drugs is essential
mithapristone is used to carry out more
than half of all abortions in this
country it was approved by the FDA 23
years ago Mr Prestone is one of the
safest medications we have it went
through not just a normal FDA approval
process but was really held to a higher
standard polling fines more than six in
ten Americans think abortion should be
legal in all or most cases those numbers
have a few Republicans like South
Carolina Congresswoman Nancy mace
pushing for a more moderate approach
with later gestational limits and
exceptions for rape and incest I see the
pulse of everyday Americans on both
sides of the aisle men and women alike
and they are not with us they're not
with the extreme far-right crazy nut
jobs that want to go to these extreme
places
the justice department has appealed
these new abortion pill restrictions to
the Supreme Court but if the nine
justices don't weigh in by the end of
the date today those restrictions will
start to go into effect across the
country tomorrow Vlad
all right Nancy Cordis reporting for us
Nancy thank you